for years Nicholas sturgeon seemed as
solid as Arthur's seat the ancient
volcano that Towers over Edinburgh but
political and geological eras both end
Arthur's seat stopped erupting 340
million years ago sturgeon's power
disappeared with her resignation
announcement last Wednesday
good morning everyone so the Scottish
national party is now looking for a new
leader and A New Path they are now in a
state of flux and the key question for
them is what do you do about
independence what's the independent
strategy Andy McKeever is a political
analyst who watches Scottish politics
closely it comes back to the decision
that the UK Supreme Court made at the
back end of last year where they said
the Scottish Parliament did not have the
power to hold a referendum by itself
Nicholas surgeon's answer to that
question was what she called the de
facto referendum in other words she
would take a national election like the
general election that we expect next
year and she would turn that into a vote
on Independence but many in the SNP saw
this as too risky and it looks like the
tactic is now dead in the water a
special Party Conference where sturgeon
would have argued for it has been called
off for now
appetite for an imminent rerun of the
2014 referendum is falling and recent
polls suggest pro-independence has
become a minority view once again
Nicholas sturgeon's exit May further
erode support I hope it doesn't why
because I want independence you
Independence yeah so what are your hopes
and fears for who's next and what they
can do I don't know it's come as quite a
shock her last mistake will put back the
cause for Independence because
it's never been more than 50 percent
that don't know as many of them will I
think vote to stay in the union because
you know
we've lost the European Union
we probably don't want to lose the
longest Union in the world whoever's
next will have to reinvigorate the
independence cause and fend off
opposition party sensing an opportunity
the race for a new SMP leader and
Scottish first Minister doesn't yet have
a clear front-runner candidates have
until Friday to enter and then it's a
six-week contest with the members having
until the end of March to make their
choice
a choice that will Usher in a new
political age for Scotland Rory
challenge Al Jazeera Edinburgh